all right asia
where did you grow up where are you from
originally originally from california oh
really los angeles but you're living in
new jersey now until it was three and
then we moved to brooklyn lived there
till i was nine and then we moved to new
jersey
to lakewood new jersey
so you tell me about your family and how
you grew up
well because my parents were extremely
religious the
first fault i would say for all of us as
children in our family growing up was
the belief that birth control was a sin
and that every child that is granted and
every pregnancy that is granted
is a gift from god
so
my mother was procreating at an alarming
rate and she was pregnant a total of 13
times and as messed up as it sounds
thank god only eight of us survived
because
they weren't financially in a situation
where they could take care of eight kids
they weren't mentally regulated and
mentally stable enough to take care of
eight kids
and as a result
my family life was pretty terrifying
pretty scary pretty nerve-wracking and
never feeling safe
so your family's religious background
you get you're acidic
we're both ultra-orthodox and there's
also hasidic in the family as well so
there's both in the family
but their spectrums of ultra-orthodoxy
and their spectrums of acidicness
so
there can be people that are
ultra-orthodox that are even more
religious than hasidics
so it's almost like it's a contest who
can be
more pious more devout
more restrictive
and more cultish is it is it
almost competitive
it's a mold and the mold is
one way of being and if you're not going
to fit that mold unless you surpass that
mold to an unnatural state of sinless
behavior
your goal is to always fit that mold and
if you're not going to fit that mold
you are desecrating the holy name of god
again when we're kids
it is drilled into us we are god's
chosen
we are to be a light unto the nation we
are hated because we are god's chosen
people and as a child
that's not something i wanted to hear
that i was hated you know what i mean
i wanted to be liked i didn't want to be
hated and i didn't want all this
pressure
and i would say as a child we learn a
lot of very
bloody paganistic things in our religion
that no child should ever witness for
example there's this
holiday called rosh hashanah where it's
like the day of atonement where we
um
repent for our sins and
in order to repent for our sins
there would be a bunch of live chickens
and the girls would be in one group and
the boys would be in one group
and they would pick up the live chickens
and they would weigh them over our heads
and see these blessings and i remember
we'd all duck terrified that the
chickens were gonna poop on us
and i remember very young girl in
brooklyn watching the chickens get
slaughtered running around in circles
with the blood shooting out of their
necks
and you know we were told that all those
chickens were going to go to charity and
feed the poor
but you know
in the name of religion we were just
exposed to things
that
most
kids i know nowadays are not exposed to
and it sounds like it didn't really fit
into who you wanted to be
you were you were uncomfortable with
that whole
i think that anybody who feels
restricted
is not going to feel happy if you are
doing something any religion anything
you do
that you feel forced you feel restricted
you feel obligated and pressured
there's not going to be any love for it
and it always came in a way of fear in a
way of you're going to go to hell you're
going to get an early death
there would be all sorts of things being
told to us at the age of three i wasn't
allowed to walk
more it's called for anybody who's
watching this that wants to question
it's called dalit ammo we're not allowed
to walk a certain amount of feet
until we wash our hands in eagle vosser
which means
we wash off the impurities of our sleep
at age three already i have to perform
this ritual
and we're taught that the water that we
use is so impure that if we were to
drink it
shade him which our demons will come and
attack us
so like we're learning very
uh
crazy things as children and
having that as your foundation
if you're a strong-willed child like me
who's gonna question and not necessarily
just follow
you're going to have a hard time and
that was the kind of child that i was i
none of it made sense i was always
somebody who cared about fairness and
justice
and i didn't see any of that
so
i remember like you know even just this
might sound really stupid but
just having to in the summer
dress in all those layers
would be
so hard for me that you know when you
know i was
you know in camp i would always roll
down my socks or
do those little things and just
you know just show like it was so bad
and so sinful and i was waiting for that
lightning to come strike me down
and i remember even as a little kid like
being terrified of my mother because
like she walked into the pool area
and immediately i can demonstrate for
you what i did because i realized my
socks were rolled down how dare i in 90
degrees
have my socks roll down
and i immediately clutched my stomach
and i bent down and i had this big dress
which immediately covered my bare legs
mind you i'm still wearing my thick
socks that are you know rolled down and
i'm like oh my stomach hurts you know so
that she wouldn't hit me
you know cause
that's what she did
she was a hitter
you know she reacted she didn't respond
and you know she was just
looking back now i can understand that
in her mind
being
the most pious and being
the most religious
was her badge of honor
and her daughter
her not seeing me as my own human being
and as a
branch of her
you know that was punishment
and that was not tolerated
and at a very young age i realized i
didn't belong
and i was going to have to fit in
and that just never sat well with me
i never could fit in
i had too much of a big mouth i had too
much of a mind
and this is not a
circle where individuality is praised
it is absolutely terrifying to be an
individual
you need to be
a penguin you know they all wear the
black and the white you need to be part
of the tribal penguin community
apologies to the community for saying
that
but you know that's what it felt like
you know everybody's you know in the
same
clothing and i feel very much like i am
an individual and i'm not somebody that
you know
i am a black sheep
you have to think for yourself
also what i learned is being a black
sheep makes you no less valuable it just
makes you
a different color sheep
we're all
the same on the inside if we're
different on the outside it's just the
outside we all are the same
but unfortunately when you're in these
super duper secluded closed off elitist
communities
i was watching that episode with the
klansman
and
i feel like my father is exactly like
him extremely separatist extremely
elitist
if he would see me speak with someone of
another the race would threaten to send
me
to the to israel
um extremely homophobic extremely
the klansmen had more
open mind than my father
i feel like in these in they they've
internalized the holocaust where i live
it feels like the ghettos of warsaw
they
the women are shaving their heads when
they get married the boys are getting
their heads shaved why are women getting
their heads shaved that has nothing to
do with religion it has nothing to do
with modesty it feels as if
like they took this trauma of all
being told
that you know they belong in ovens and
they really kind of internalized it and
in leekwood it feels like
you know
they just never they dress the same they
look the same like in europe
it's almost like they even say things
like they have to procreate as much as
possible to make up for all the jews
that hitler murdered
they say crazy things you know they
don't drive german cars
they carry the grudge
the dna has switched up
and if you
dare
want to go outside you're a trader
you're you're 100 a trader
you they'll say things to you like your
people died because they were jews and
you're willingly going and marrying a
non-jew how dare you
they'll shame you
and use guilt and shame
to major major manipulation tactics
to keep you
so what kind of things did you go
through as a
child as a teenager you know what you
you must have at some point started to
break away from your family so i would
say the first
core traumatic memory for me which
started
me really
having a huge issue with covering up
and
having a huge issue
is
we lived in a two-family home in
brooklyn and
there wasn't a lot of supervision and
because there was nothing ever to do in
our house we would always be downstairs
and there was teenage boys downstairs
and they would torture me now that i
think about it always running their
bikes into me
pretty horrible stuff like at parties
stealing my candy that i would collect
and stuff like that
but one time we were downstairs and i
obviously didn't understand what was
happening at the time you know
now i i do understand but you know like
people have those washing machine and
dryers where they have those sliding
doors
so me and the girl
the young girl the sister of the teenage
boy
he put us
on top of the washing machine and dryer
he closed the doors
and
he
violated us
and
the mother
of the downstairs neighbor walked in
pulled open the doors sauce naked
and
screamed
she
violently slapped her daughter
chased her son away and told me to go
upstairs to my house
now that night
i didn't think anything of it you know
that night
i remember
being yanked by my hair in my sleep out
of my bed
and being dragged from my bedroom all
the way down there was a long long long
hallway and it went through the living
room the dining room the kitchen the
bathroom the closets all the way through
the whole house my mother was dragging
me by my hair
she lifted me my hair threw me face down
on the bed
and yanked my pants down
and she began smacking me over and over
again really really hard and she began
to scream don't you ever
ever ever
be
unsweetest again which means a modest
and then she took me and threw me off
the bed
go back to sleep and um
sobbing hysterically
not understanding
what the [ __ ] just happened
but my mother was a very violent woman
and when my mother would enlist my
father when she would just
she was always hormonal and pregnant and
if i come across as i'm defending her
it's more that i'm trying to understand
her
now as an adult versus
being a victim
so
like when my father hit us would leave
marks bad ones like pop blood vessels in
her eyes and swollen cheeks and i was
the kid who went to school and would say
things like i walked in a door
and my mother was the kind of woman who
like if you just like tapped her in the
wrong place she would flip around and
just slap you really hard because you
were just trying to get her attention
she was extremely full of rage and anger
and just always resorted to violence
which terrified me because i'm somebody
who doesn't walk on antels
so like i'm such a
gentle
person so that type of fear
resulted in me you know till this day
you know having heart palpitations and
gut issues because
you never knew she was just so
unpredictable like if you said you
didn't like dinner
she would do things like force feed us
put a timer on and if you didn't eat
she would make like stuff like buckwheat
what five-year-old wants to eat
buckwheat like kasha
and she would put a timer on and if you
didn't finish that food she would send
you to bed without dinner you didn't get
your homework done and you would tell
the teacher sorry your homework wasn't
done and signed she would do like crazy
crazy weird ass things
that are not normal
because it didn't dawn on her that maybe
her kids had sensory issues and didn't
like certain foods
um
there's just
such weird things like if i would
accidentally
there would was a snowball fight that we
had and i threw a snowball on my brother
and not realizing there was like a shard
of ice in it and i caught his head open
by mistake
i got such a beating my whole side of my
face was so blown up and bloody that my
father actually apologized to me
my parents never apologized for hitting
us even if they made a mistake
my mother would say well god must have
felt you deserved it if i hit you
things would be bad to the point where i
remember going paddle boating on a lake
and i remember lifting my skirts like
right above my knees
and you know i'm 50 russian so i have
the pale skin but i also could tan
so
i got really bad burns
and i was too scared to tell my mother
because i knew my mother would say well
why were you a modest of course you're
going to get punished
anytime there was a
sexual violation or an assault it was
what did you do what were you wearing
it was always
it's your fault there was always the
victim blaming
always
it was never let's not invite the creep
over
let's make sure you cover up more
it was always
your fault not
he's an animal he's a monster he's a
demon he's broken
and the excuse was when i was confronted
my parents about this was we didn't know
any better
but my friends
kind of grew up in the same type of
situation and their parents did
change and did get help so i feel like
that's just a cop-out i feel like it's
an excuse
because
if you really want
to know better
you will
so
kids make excuses adults make changes
you know
there's only
so much denial
i can take before i realize like certain
people if their brain is broken
it's healthier to just
separate
and that's another thing that i strongly
advise people to do is if your family is
not committed to healing
get away
if you can use religion
as an excuse
to harbor
criminals
you know you have to question
what your religion is
and i say that to the people that are
doing that right now and
know who they are
um
it's a very sad thing that you know
in a lot of very religious cultures
there's
i'm going to get religious on all of us
for a second there is a song we sing on
the sabbath and it's called
asia's heil and there is a
line in it
that says
which means that we glorify lies
and we uglify beauty which means let's
say
we
think that when someone abstains from
promiscuity that they're prude and that
they're bad
because they care about sexual health
and they want to be celibate and they
want to have meaningful sexual
relationships you get scoffed at for
that
but
somebody who goes and makes 50 million
dollars off of porn is going to be
praised
so
in the same right in our religious
culture
they're going to take the ugliness
and they're going to hide it they won't
necessarily beautify it but they're
going to hide it
and
the beauty
of the people who have the courage to
speak up
those people are going to get punished
those people are going to get cursed
those people are going to be found dead
those people are going to be found
blackmailed because there's like a whole
underworld going on in these super
religious
circles where they have their own police
they have their own if there's uh even
the
landlord uh abuse
there's organizations
they have like their whole there's a
whole underworld going on
loaning and getting people out of
trouble and
lawyers and it's good but it's also bad
because let's say if somebody
it's very hard but you know i think it's
important to speak about it because not
everybody goes through it so
there is no test and testimony so
if you
love someone and you have a sibling you
have no idea
is
mentally ill
because they didn't harm you they didn't
choose you as a victim
and
you're told
one day that this person is going to
jail for 10 years because
they're a pedophile
you actually do go into denial you can't
believe it at first because this is
this is your blood this is your family
this is your protector this is someone
who took beatings for you this is
somebody
and you know i can even understand like
not to go off on a tangent like why
nicki minaj would defend her brother
because there's this
you can't accept in the beginning that
this is actually the truth you can't
it's
so mind-boggling
but
you then find out hey
there was pedophiles in the family
already
this person was a victim there it's
already been going on
and
what's so [ __ ] up is
these songs that they're singing and
they're you know being all religious
they're just all living a lie because
they're not outing these perpetrators
they're not outing these people they're
protecting them they're hiding it
instead of saying you know what this
person is broken this person needs to be
put the [ __ ] away this person needs to
be
put away from society not
quickly run off to another country or
keep it a secret or be angry at the
people who outed them
and
you know as the famous saying goes if
you enable an abuser you are an abuser
and in the beginning when i found out
that
i was related to
the worst sort of human i mean
even murderers aren't treated as
horrible as people who harm children
and it's like something you just
you die
you die
how do you come back from that how do
you
how do you heal
how do you
heal and i kept quiet because i was so
ashamed
i kept quiet and i didn't see anything
and everybody just keeps quiet
but it's
time to [ __ ] speak up it's time to
you know you keep doing the same thing
over and over again as the definition of
insanity so we need different results
you know because it's gonna keep
happening
what's so crazy is that i had mentioned
that you know we repeat cycles
so
um
when i met my
i was
very young very naive and this was
obviously before i had any awareness
that
pedophilia was in my family
uh premarital sex is not acceptable in
in our culture you're a virgin i mean
you're terrified and
if you're
you dare
you don't get to come home you know what
i mean there's a lot of fear there's a
lot of emotional intimidation and
emotional manipulation at a very young
age and you feel fear
and hatred because you cannot love what
you fear
so
shockingly for me like when i hit
puberty
i
did not turn to men
i turned to numb myself like well
everybody was running to go hook up and
have their first kiss
i
was going to
well what i had to do was my parents
just didn't give a [ __ ] that i was
slowly dying so i started to self-harm i
started to starve myself i started to
you know
anything to get their attention that i
wasn't okay and this started when i was
about 13 years old and it was like
getting to high school time because
i was
just so alienated and so hated in the
schools and the teachers were constantly
sending me to the principal
and what's insane is the principals
would call my parents and say what's
going on with her was she molested and
they would say no
no
and meanwhile i wasn't gotten beaten for
it
and of course i was
acting immodest
like that was my biggest crime was that
i wanted to fold up my sleeves and that
i wanted my top button opened
and that my skirt wasn't four inches
below my knee or four inches above my
ankle like it can't be too long and it
can't be too short like i mean they
literally pull out the [ __ ] rulers
when i see a cult i'm not kidding it's
really and they'll do it in front of the
whole class
so
it's almost like i had a reverse
reaction to that when i was five six
years old it was like no i don't want to
cover up no i don't want to walk around
like a [ __ ] nun
no i want to express myself i want to be
an individual i want to be
like it almost felt like everybody was
afraid of me and
weirdly enough i did have a certain
power over my class like sometimes i
would tell them stories and the whole
class would be crying and then i would
get sent home for three days and then i
would come back and everybody would have
balloons and cards for me
because like
sometimes like my pain would be so
palpable
that
i would have the whole class crying
because
our town was so small and i wasn't
accepted to any high schools so like
everybody had a place to go not me
and my parents weren't wise enough at
the time to
realize she doesn't fit in we can't
instead of them saying okay we need to
send her where she belongs we're going
to
bring in
our
our um
our credentials
[ __ ] what she like needs because we what
we come to the table and our dynasty and
where we come from holds way more weight
than what you are
and
they said you need to take her and they
would bring up all these religious rules
and laws about why they have to take her
and when you're being put into a
situation where you know you're hated
you know you're not wanted you know your
very core
is despised
how are you supposed to go to that place
how are you supposed to go where your
core is hated
and you know it
because they said you're not accepted
so i began to self-harm as a cry for
help
so
i got shipped off to memphis tennessee
which was a complete culture shock
so going to the south was
i got introduced to
for the first time
this is going to sound shocking
and
i never knew that
i was
even remotely
decent looking or
was pleasing to the eye
until i was shipped off to boarding
school because all of a sudden i was in
a boarding school and
everybody was disgusting to me because
again there was individuality we could
dress
to a certain extent you know i was still
was
in you know it was like for you know
kids like me who didn't have anywhere to
go but they still wanted to keep us
in the gates in the walls and the
institution
but with a little more leeway you
understand my parents just couldn't deal
with me the schools weren't taking me it
was they were forced
so i'm this
young little girl in memphis and that's
when the bullying starts and that's when
i'm exposed to being hated for existing
again for just being who i am
and
i just
was an innocent
good little religious girl like
didn't grow up with the tv internet
nothing
and immediately the rumors would start i
would get called to the principal's
office again the cycle would start uh
they said that you were on the swing and
you were spreading your legs open
i basically
couldn't handle like being around
like
all the bullying so i left early and i
went overseas to israel
and i went to another school for
children at risk and like that's when i
like
really got locked down like if i did
something wrong i would be locked in the
house for two months not be able to
leave
um
it was it was crazy car bombs would be
going off i was 16 years old
almost felt like my parents were hoping
i'd die you know
but anyways
that's when um
you know i met my first boyfriend and
experienced you know what it was like to
in my own
way
you know
experience a man that
but it was terrifying for me and i
couldn't be healthy
so that relationship could never
be explored in a healthy teen manner
so uh when i came back from israel i
was pretty young and
met
another person another guy who was you
know about eight years older than me who
was more established had a home
and i was obviously miserable coming
back from israel where i had all that
freedom
because i was in israel for two years so
the first year yeah i was in like a
lockdown kind of military at risk type
of school but then the second year
i had freedom so i was able to do
whatever i wanted and i was able to
party and explore and actually be
and you know be a teen
so when i came back
i needed to get the [ __ ] out of my house
because you can't go from having freedom
to going back into you know basically
being in jail
to like a crazy degree where you can't
even read books that are secular it's
called secular like we would only be
able to read
jewish books and not even all jewish
books
so i met a guy
and according to jewish law if a guy's
mom is jewish he's by law a jew but in
our circles he would
be considered an ignoramus
uh half-breed not considered
anything up to par for what my parents
would accept long story short my ex went
to israel to prove to my parents that he
was serious about me
my ex was a serious conqueror at the
time i mean i was a virgin and i mean
that's unheard of you know
that was like a treasure to him and
he also like my mom would like try to
set me up because in religious circles
like you go on like pre-arranged dates
and it's a quick process like my niece
was engaged for she got like she was
probably dating at 17 she was engaged at
18 when she got engaged within two
months she was married
so like her frontal lobe isn't even
fully developed and at 18 she's married
and she's going to immediately procreate
and her life is going to be about
serving a man having babies and never
discovering anything about herself
unless she has a wake-up call one day
so
my ex
he came in the form of everything that i
had ever dreamt of beautiful
tall
handsome
more financially stable than i was
and
wasn't religious
so you know this was jackpot for me
but this was unacceptable for my parents
obviously because you can't live in a
man's home
not married so
i was forced to get married to him
and our wedding was insane we i mean
i
was
so messed up at my wedding i was like a
sheep led to my to the slaughter at my
wedding it was a religious wedding which
was crazy because my ex
like
his
he has like most of his family's not
even jewish so like he you know
completely different culture shock
and of course my parents like in the
religious world everybody has to bow to
them everybody has to bow to their
mythical beliefs it's like you know the
person who's allergic to the peanut you
know every nobody can bring the peanut
around them so it was a super religious
wedding i had like
everything
uh
so
damn
now it gets to the crazy part so when
you get married there's something called
nida which is one of the most
dehumanizing degrading things that a
woman goes through we're told that we're
impure when we have our periods we are
not allowed to be touched
we are not allowed to have sex a man is
not allowed to hand us anything they
have to put it down
all right let me get into how degrading
this this this thing that we have to do
so when we get our period
um
we're deemed impure so once our period
is over you have to then count
seven clean days after your period
if you're unsure
if your period if you can start counting
the seven clean days
and wait i'm gonna jump ahead and why is
that because if you think about the math
when are you ovulating you ovulate at
that time
so it's to have babies if you think
about how it's set up it's totally set
up so that the woman gets pregnant
so
for whatever reason i'm sure it comes
from paganistic beliefs
they believe a woman is considered
impure when she bleeds
so
um
i know this because my mother's a mikvah
lady so they have something called a
mikvah and men go to it once a week
before the sabbath and the women go when
they're married before their wedding and
they go to it every single time they
have their period and it's a way for
also like for sexual coercion because
it's like they claim it's a commandment
that you have to procreate with your
husband
once you count your seven clean days
you then have to go to it's these hidden
buildings you have to pay a fee
you have to go in you have to do a whole
ritualistic bath you have to
have your nails have to be cut down
there's like a whole list of things like
a long list of 30 steps that you have to
take then the woman comes in and
inspects you from top to bottom and then
again makes you go over the list and
then you have to like take another one
another shower and then this is the
funniest part
they take you to a chlorine-filled pool
that's filled with pubes and filled with
nasty disgusting everybody else's germs
after you've just been
cleaned and scrubbed
to the raw bone of your skin like i'm
saying like the laws are insane like you
cannot have a knot in any of your hair
you're not allowed to have any nail
growing out or a cuticle like the laws
are so rigid and strict they're insane
so what happens is that you take off
your robe you're naked you go down the
stairs into the small pool
you have to make a blessing
and then you have to dip
three times and the lady looks
and she
you have to do like a special dip a
certain way and she says either kosher
or not culture and then you have to do
it again
and then after you do it you come out
and the woman puts the robe back on you
and you're deemed pure again
and you go home and you go your husband
gets laid
so
imagine being told because your body
works and because you're healthy you're
impure
if there's anything more insulting
that you cannot be touched that you
cannot be loved on also when they have
babies
for like those eight weeks
you can't be touched
like the baby has to be put down
there's like all of these insane crazy
rituals that are going on
so
when i met my ex
i told him about all these things and he
swore to me that i would never have to
fear that this would happen that he
would protect me and we would never we
would have the best of both worlds that
we could have all the
the the foods that we loved and we could
have all the traditional foods but we
would also have our american life and we
would also
have tv we would have hbo we'd have
cable we would go to the beach we'd do
all the things
eat pork
do all the things that
you know i didn't get to do growing up
but what's crazy is is that my ex
decided that he wanted to become
religious
and one of the most insane things is he
would start telling the rabbi's daughter
that she was the bad you
talk about repeating cycles
so
all of a sudden my clothing that he
loved
about me weren't acceptable anymore my
nipples were sticking out why are you
dressing like a 12 year old girl why are
you looking like that
no you can't go out on the sabbath i'm
taking your keys away no you can't go to
your bachelorette he would start doing
crazy
of control crazy
so
like
that's
when you know like the irony
of the psycho repeating itself
but that wasn't enough
so
our marriage started to disintegrate
because when you're going one path and
you're going another path you're growing
apart you're not growing together
so
my ex is
basically
would say to me the reason why our
marriage isn't working out is because we
don't have a kid
we don't have a [ __ ] kid that is why
we're fighting all the time if you just
gave me a kid
we would
we would be happy and me being young
dumb ignorant and naive you know
everybody knows
a child doesn't save a marriage
you know therapy was never something
that came to mind i went to therapy but
he you know the one time he did him and
the therapist got into a huge fight
immediately
so that you know
so
i got pregnant and i remember thinking
me the hopeless romantic that he was
gonna come home and sweep me off my feet
and swing me around in a circle and have
a big bouquet of roses and he was on the
phone for 30 minutes on a business call
he didn't even look at me
my pregnancy was vicious
and my pregnancy
i
didn't know
that i had rights to my body i didn't
know that i had to have someone who
despised me baby
i didn't know that i was you know being
reproductively coerced and
i realized when he came home and grew
like didn't even acknowledge me that i
had finally given him a baby that he had
waited so long for
that we were all [ __ ]
and this wasn't the answer so
when i was pregnant
i i prayed for miscarriage i did because
i was terrified for my child i felt
guilty i was doing to my child what my
mother had done to me
but
after a vicious pregnancy and
a horrible labor
when my baby was put in my arms
the mother in me was born
the mother of me was not born when i was
pregnant
the mother in me was born when she was
born
and that is when the lioness came out
and that is when the courage came out
and i would say
it's such a great story i don't know if
you know the yom kippur is the holiest
day of the year in our culture it's the
day of fasting we start the night fast
my daughter was
around one and a half years old and i
had already let my ex know you know i'm
not fasting i'm gonna be watching tv i'm
gonna be breaking the fast
and i let him know
and my ex was somebody who's like in
laker jerseys and tims and like you know
we listen to dipset and like he's coming
in with his like big prayer shawl like
it was like literally
a stranger like it was like my dad
walking in you know what i mean like
so he comes in
and the tv is on and i must probably
have like love and hip hop on or
something
and he's just like my dad in the
klansmen type of way very republican
very right wing
and
he
becomes furious and he had just repented
for all his sensum kippers about
cleansing of the soul repenting
and he violently kicks my daughter's toy
right because he doesn't want to kick me
so he violently kicks my daughter's toy
and it goes sailing right by her face
and it literally like a half an inch
from her face
and for the first time in my life i know
it's a holy day my religion is always
going to be in me it's wired no matter
what that spirituality is there and i'm
like you know what
i picked up my daughter and i went into
the garage and i held her in my arms and
for the first time in many many many
years
i prayed and i said one thing to god i
said god
get me out of here
get me
out of here
and within two months
we had separated
and my faith had been a little bit
restored i'm not gonna lie you know like
no matter how much i had doubted
whatever whatever
powers that be it's you know a lot of
people say do you believe in god and i
can't answer that question because i do
feel
whether it be the holy ghost whatever it
is i do feel it i feel a protection i
feel a spirituality and a deep
connection
but
leaving unfortunately did not protect my
daughter
as a result
if you leave the community the power is
going to always go to the person that
stays in the community so my daughter is
still stuck in the community my daughter
like there's a lot of pros to being in
the community my daughter uh
first of all like being that my
daughter's father is now a single father
he's gonna get taken care of very well
by all you know it's a very tribal
thing which is
a very
something that we are missing nowadays
that you know very religious communities
do have and i admit that a lot of people
are reclusive so there's a lot to be
gained for him to be in the religious
circles
they're gonna
always
you know make things cheaper for him
because he's the single father keeping
her in the expense of religious jewish
school there's just so many scams and
there's just so many ways to
prey upon religious people and there's
so many benefits
i know
because i'm from it
i know that there's
a lot of really good things that come
with religion as well why because it's
commanded
so
the fight is still going because my
daughter has expressed
so many times how much she hates being
forced to pray
she's forced to pray she's in a
religious school where she has to wear
skirts and she has to do the same things
the sleeves don't have to be till here
but they have to be till here so it's a
little bit less
but the same people that are running the
schools i were in they're running them
too
so
we are
in this battle of
not a battle a journey
it's called a journey
because
we're going to make this a journey and
we're not going to make it a battle
we're in this journey
so that my daughter doesn't have to feel
fear
course of control manipulation and
intimidation
and i'm not sure how that's going to be
and i don't have all the answers but i
promise her every single time that i see
her that it won't be like this forever
and that she won't be forced to fit in
and that she will be in a place where
she belongs
and that is my promise to her and that
is why i came here today
so that if she ever
doubts
ever
that this journey isn't about her
she is the biggest blessing that i
didn't want
and she gives me courage
and she is the reason
that i find my inner power every single
day and without her
i don't think i would be alive
so
this journey is for her
so that she
has the freedom of choice
to have a fulfilling life without
triggers without fears without beatings
without
getting slapped for turning on a light
on the sabbath by accident
so that she doesn't have to know that so
that she can have choices and that she
can have options
what i was born into
i would get sick before i would have to
go to functions
i would have to be
on things and i would show up shaking
super duper hard
i
you know my mother would loudly be like
why are you shaking so hard you know and
at the time i didn't realize
because
the environment was sick and it was
making me sick
so
it took a little while
it took repeating the cycle
you know marrying i didn't just marry my
mother i married my mother and my father
and in our culture you know i did
something which is completely
against the rules which is you know i
found someone that wasn't in our circles
and we're constantly taught that
marriage is very hard as it is so you're
supposed to find someone as close
to you
as your background as possible so that
you can at least understand each other
but what's so interesting is
i was always around my family we all
came from that background and
my family couldn't stand me and was
ashamed of me and you know what i mean
so there was just a huge contradiction
with that
and
what i learned is
blood is not thicker than water
i learned that the bonds of the heart
and soul
are way way stronger
than the bonds of family
you know
i've seen that dogs show more love than
humans
you know we grow up where we don't have
animals they're deemed impure they're
dirty
and
you know i didn't know what it meant to
love until i got a dog
because as cesar milan says you don't
get the dog you want you get the dog you
need and i thought i was going to get me
and this will tell you about my
personality the first dog i got was a
pit bull
and i didn't know what i was getting
myself into and i thought i was going to
get me a cute little dog that was going
to sit on my side and was going to be a
couch potato and oh she was a hellion
she i i hated her why because i was
selfish and i didn't realize
you don't get the dog you want you get
the dog you need so i remember watching
a lot of dog whisperer
and started learning about
putting her needs before mine
discipline
exercise then affection well it's really
exercise discipline and affection
and what was amazing is through that
relationship through a dog was for the
first time i learned unconditional love
i learned
you don't have to look a certain way you
don't have to dress a certain way you
don't have to be perfect you don't have
to be anything you can
just be
and i learned through dogs you don't
need to speak because love and loyalty
doesn't need words it's through action
my favorite line is dog is god backwards
you know i felt
that i had missed out
on just such basic necessities that
human beings
don't realize that they take for granted
i remember when i would watch my first
disney movies
till this day
i love to watch disney movies like i
never got to be a child when you're one
of eight kids and i was the middle i was
number four so the older kids dumped
everything on me and i protected my
younger siblings
and i was also an easy target because
um
i am neurodivergent so i blurt things
out i like i don't know how to sometimes
shut the [ __ ] up you understand so
that's gonna immediately get a slap in
the face
um
and that's another thing for people who
suffer with neurodivergent
whatever whatever severity you are on
the spectrum
i do believe that you know we do get
along better with
other neurodivergents more than we do
with
neurotypical people and my humblest
opinion unless neurotypical people are
going to be committed to understanding
that our brains are spider webs and not
staircases
you know
and i feel like a lot of people
are afraid of labels and they're afraid
to get diagnosed and you should not be
afraid of labels because if you get
diagnosed and you understand that your
brain might operate a different way you
can then live your life according to the
way your brain operates if your brain is
a scattered deck of cards you can then
learn how to hack it
but you know in our culture there's like
this big stigma and there's this big
shame with therapy as well
and something that i'm so proud of is
that i'm so pro-therapy and
if i could because focusing is something
that's hard for me
one day if i could
become
healed enough
in my own trauma that i could
heal others because
humbly there isn't anything that i
haven't been through
in my journey
to where i am today
so
what will make me feel fulfilled in life
i've searched
when you
are told you are chosen and you are
special and you don't feel it
and you go out on your search and you
search
i think that what is most fulfilling for
me has always been
to give
and to heal
and to be a student of life
and to always to grow and to be humble
in my lack of knowledge
and to be around people that won't
belittle me but will educate me when i
make mistakes
and i really
know that there are so many people in
this world that are so misunderstood and
are being punished for their pain
because they're misunderstood
and i really hope that there will be a
time that my own brain will be regulated
that i could go back to school
and get out of the beauty industry
because you know
that's like another thing like when
you're in
a cult
your external appearance is everything
you have to look the part always that
mask has to be on it doesn't matter
what's going on behind closed doors
what's not nice we don't show
and i want to embrace being around
people where we talk about the dirty
stuff that's what attracted me so much
about your channel
is that
we're not masking
we're not pretending
this is reality
this is what's going on in the world and
all the children that are being born
are being born to the people that you're
interviewing
and we have to break these cycles
because these children are all going to
end up dead
because
all of my friends are dead
i should be dead so
we're punishing people for being in pain
we're punishing people because they've
had to learn to adapt
to being in situations that they didn't
choose
what is adhd
tuning out we develop it as kids because
we have to adapt we have to learn to
tune things out
and we grow up and we become adults and
it goes into adulthood addiction
i don't believe we're born addicts i
believe addiction
is
the symptom of trauma
how are people who don't
have coping skills
learn to cope healthy
the first thing that they're gonna get
that's gonna quiet their brain that's
gonna help them sleep that's gonna
quiet the pain
they're gonna run to
we have a system where we're punishing
people for being in pain we're punishing
people for being in trauma
and
we have nobody to stand up for these
people instead we're throwing them in
jail they're getting a policy number
they're being thrown in rehabs and
rehabs jails and funeral homes are never
going to be going out of business until
we change the system
and somebody is brave enough to speak up
and say enough
we have to be okay with other people not
fitting in and making choices for
themselves
as long as they're healthy and they're
not harming people we have to stop this
coercive control with religion because
it's destroying lives
and i see it just
constantly
the cycle is getting repeated again
within my own circle
and that's why i
know that if i fear
that
we'll become a victim to what i was
that's what will happen so i have to not
be afraid
i have to come with courage
and
with determination
and with belief in my own
self
that i can heal
and that i can
face my triggers
and that i can raise my daughter
so she
doesn't have to feel unwanted
because my mother was reproductively
coerced through religion
she was
in her mind she was told she was doing
the ultimate
good deed she's bringing life into this
world even if she wasn't mentally
capable of doing it financially capable
of doing it
in her mind
because she was so religiously
indoctrinated
and coercively controlled through
religion she was reproductively coerced
and i understand that
and that's why therapy is so important
is that you
don't have to forgive but you can start
to understand and become at peace
and i strongly believe that people are
terrified of therapy because therapists
a lot of therapists suck
but that doesn't mean that gives you an
excuse not to go and get help
it means you have to keep searching for
the right therapist
just like not every doctor is a good
doctor
just like not everybody in their field
should be in their field if you are
committed to getting help
that is what makes you strong
and i'll give a perfect parable
a lot of times we go to the bathroom to
take a crap right and we sit in there on
our phones and we're scrolling
and we don't realize how bad the
bathroom smells because we're sitting
there right
after we finally get up and get out we
open the door and we get out of the
bathroom you smell the fresh air for the
first time we're like how the hell was i
sitting in that nasty bathroom
that's what therapy's about
you're basically sitting in your [ __ ]
you're sitting and wallowing in your
ship finding band-aids to put on
yourself
when you can go and yes it's terrifying
it's so scary at first to be broken and
to feel that pain
it's so scary
but nobody ever died from crying
but people are going to die from putting
needles in their arms
and you have a choice do you want to
take this one life that you have and do
you want to make it something fulfilling
or do you want to keep running from your
pain
and i know it's not easy as you get
older i know it's not easy it's
so hard because all the systems are
designed to keep you hooked
in whatever
trauma induced coma you are in whether
you're in a religious cult whether
you're in the throes of addiction
prostitution
you're institutionalized and you know
your institution and
you got used to smelling that [ __ ]
and you got comfortable in it
but you don't know that if you open that
door that ear is so beautiful and so
pure
and so clean
and so fulfilling and so healthy
and
that's the journey that i'm on right now
i ran
i tried to run
but there is no running it catches up
with you
and
there was something inside of me that
didn't want to be controlled either you
know when you want to run away from your
pain
you're going to be controlled by
whatever it is
that you're using to numb the pain
whatever it is
so
i want to feel
not in control because none of us are in
control
we are only in control in our mind we
are a slave to our circumstances as
always at the end of the day
but what i would like to do is i would
like to have control of my mind
i would have would like to have a
regulated mind
where i respond i don't react or i can
work through my triggers
where i have that inner power and that
inner peace
and that is my journey
and a journey that i'm eager to embark
on even though it's scary
because you have to be broken for it
but i'm here for it
because what i can say is
the rat race of chasing the band-aid is
never going to end
but there is a light
and the light
it doesn't
come at the end of the tunnel there's
cracks of it that come while you're
going through the tunnel and you see it
and you feel it and it's so beautiful
and every time you see that crack of
light that gives you that push to get
towards that end
it's so rewarding and it's
you thank yourself for your courage and
your bravery
to get through the pain
of giving up the band-aids
it's not easy though
but nothing worth having ever is
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in all of this
to forgive myself
for the lack of awareness and the lack
of understanding
for the situations that i was in
to not have the regret the resentment
and the self-pity that i harbored
all right asia thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you so much for
having me beautiful
thank you very much
you